[Music]
I've always liked Peter Pan he's my
favorite keeps me young keeps me having
fun keeps me focused on not all work all
the time you have to relax and you have
to enjoy live as well hi I'm Kristy and
I live in Georgetown Kentucky I'm a
medical coder with Georgetown Hospital
so I bought a home here in Georgetown
back in 2003 bought my house in July I
made one payment and I got called in to
the office at work and was told that
they were doing away with my position
and that was it so I had 29 years and 11
months of mortgage payments and no job a
single so it was 100% income loss to the
household it's a very scary time I knew
I had to do something
to get moving I couldn't just sit around
and be bitter and disappointed so I
found a job here locally I had a bank
and I was making $8 an hour it was
enough to pay the bills never missed a
payment never got behind on anything it
was good I was in a Bible study and they
were gonna be starting FPU after going
through after you you know I refused to
go into debt so if I didn't have the
money for something I just didn't do it
realized that an emergency fund probably
be a real good idea it having been
through what I had been through
I worked after-hours at Cracker Barrel
in the store just a couple nights a week
and was able to build up my six-month
emergency fund with just that money that
I thought you know I I could do better
for myself so I started looking around
for another job and I found one in town
that was almost a fifty percent pay
increase in a completely different field
I went into the medical field with
Georgetown Hospital so I had never been
at the point where I had this much money
ever the first year I sort of played
around with it put a little extra on the
house every month or so that was in 2014
and then in 2015
I started making double mortgage
payments so when I got more I kept
living on less and just applied the
extra to the mortgage payment so 2016
came and I started making triple
mortgage payments I hadn't even missed
anything it was just how I lived and my
goal I was so focused on my goal that
was the only that was the only thing I
saw you know I just had blinders on
looking at that gotta pay off the house
gotta pay off the house got to make the
mortgage payments everything became a
choice of what I rather do this or would
I rather pay off the house certainly
would I rather go to a movie or what I
rather pay off the house early would I
rather go out to eat or would I rather
pay out that everything everything came
down to that choice so I was gizelle
intense on my house because that's the
only debt I had and I I wanted to be rid
of it so I lived on about $3,600 for the
year in 2016
I had my mortgage calculator up I just
kept it up on my computer at work so
every day I could look at it just to
keep me motivated to keep me going I'm
almost there I'm almost there by the
time I got down to 2017 it was it was
small enough balance that I was getting
excited and I was able to post the last
payment to my account on September 14th
of 2017 and I actually I'm old school I
mailed it I mailed my payment and I went
to the post office that it was a
Wednesday morning and I looked up
outside the post office and the flag was
was blowing and I thought this is
freedom this is what true freedom feels
like and and I just had this weight that
was just lifted off of me and after
everything I've been through and how
hard I had fought in 33 months of these
extra payments and I was done I was
finally done and the next day I checked
my account online and the payment had
posted and I just stared at the balance
being zero it really was just surreal I
was excited but it was it's like I
couldn't quite grasp I don't I own my
house I don't have a house payment
there's not many people in America can
say I don't have a house payment it was
totally worth it at that point and I'm
done forever
[Music]
if I can do it anybody can do it
you know people will tell me yeah but
you don't have kids you don't know what
it's like I don't have a double income
household either I don't make forty
grand a year either
I started at $8 an hour and was able to
live and you know have a home got up to
ten dollars ten fifty an hour was able
to buy a car with cash and then you know
at 26,000 take home I paid off my house
I paid off more in that thirty three
months of being focused than I did the
previous twelve years combined it's just
a matter of staying focused setting your
goals and being willing to do whatever
it takes to reach those goals when I pay
off my house I was gonna go to Disney
World I'm going to Disney World this
year was it sunny if I can get mom to
agree I'm taking my parents actually
when I started paying off the house I
thought you know maybe when I pay off my
house I can take them to Disney World
that would be fun
and I can't wait to take a debt-free
trip to Disney World for a week stand
the resort's there and just in the days
having fun with no debt completely free
enjoying life it's gonna be awesome
[Music]